this is one of the most depressing like
white white pill I've ever
welcome to the white pill so Crohn's uh
people who are incompetent the
university system fleeing New York lean
Canada our country's ruined my cities
ruined my nephew's health is ruined and
the year on a positive note everything
will be fine
malice welcome back to my podcast thank
you so much I am actually really really
excited to do this
me too this should be fun I thought yeah
we always have way to wrap up the year
can we start on a very depressing note
that I think you could help me out a lot
with
okay
so my nephew just got diagnosed with
crohn's
which is obviously no joke he's five
years old and my sister is just losing
it yeah yeah it's it's no fun
um and my sister is kind of losing it of
course you know because she's the mom
and she's got a kind of act my computer
is glitching a little bit it's fine uh
act all normal but since this is
something that you are so familiar with
like food issues and so on and so forth
do you have any advice like especially
dietary like there's got to be things
that really Set It Off oh yeah I'm sure
a lot of people listening to this have
issues or have friends in the IBS
spectrum and that could be stuff that
would be very informed of them so I'd
love to hear your thoughts yeah for sure
I've had a lot of people on Crohn's go
on the diet I'm on SO the lion diet and
put their Crohn's in remission but I
mean so that's always like the last step
of the diet is do what I'm doing that
seems to work for people and little kids
also seem to heal really quickly
compared to having someone who's had an
autoimmune disorder for 15 years go on
it but I would say if she could almost
immediately eliminate all grains all
processed foods
and dairy dairy's a big one
um and soy
okay just just doing that might help
quite a bit now I'm gonna write this
down right now yeah so all grains
um
yeah yeah the big ones are like gluten
dairy soy getting rid of those can help
a lot um and then you could just see
eating as much meat as possible meat is
the that's the easiest thing on the gut
contrary to belief but it's totally
manageable I mean you have to first
believe that it's manageable with diet
and give it a try but it is manageable
with diet
um but that's really sad five-year-old
that's brutal
yeah I I mean at first I was like
kill me now right because it's like you
have to tell this five-year-old you're
never gonna be normal but then I thought
to myself you know what there's lots of
like kids who have like diabetes right
and it sucks and you can never have
candy but there's you can't tell me with
a straight face that someone who's
diabetic can't have a thriving
fulfilling Wonderful Life they just have
to have a lifestyle that's a little
different so I looked at it that way and
the fact that she was on top of it
immediately uh and that he is like such
like a resilient little kid
um like you're gonna have to get the
um good habits in place now but like
yeah you know once she's old enough to
understand like when I have this this
caused the flare-up and that's like not
you know like that correlation thing I I
don't think it's as bad the more I
thought about it the more I'm like wait
a minute I don't need to jump off a
bridge she doesn't need to drop a bridge
it sucks but it's not anywhere near as
bad as the your first gut reaction is
yeah I agree also from a parent's
perspective
um I know that when I was diagnosed with
arthritis so I was seven when I was
diagnosed it like destroyed my mom but
for me yeah because I was just not aware
of what was going on I was like ew I
have an old person disease like that was
what I felt but it wasn't like
heartbreaking emotional uh trauma it was
just like oh okay I have that I don't
want to tell anybody about it and that's
as like far as I got mentally so I think
getting diagnosed with something when
you're older is much more traumatizing
than getting diagnosed when you're young
even though even though it's more
heartbreaking when you're young I don't
think it's as hard on the kid so at
least maybe she could take some solace
in that it's probably not nearly as hard
on the kid as it is on her and that you
can treat it with diet and Scarlett's
she's five and she eats like a paleo
diet and what I've explained to her is
sometimes at school she'll have
something and then she'll run around
like crazy if it's sugar or something
like that and I'll be like that was
because you ate this and she was like
okay and she's old enough now to
understand okay some things I eat and
they hurt my tummy and some things I eat
and they do this
um it's probably better to get started
early but I mean being diagnosed with an
autoimmune disorder when you're little
is definitely not a joke
well also it's kind of funny because I I
had stomach issues all my life and then
when I was in like my like late 20s I
think it was I met someone who had
Crohn's and he told me about probiotics
and they fixed me like almost overnight
and it was just such like a wonderful
thing to be able to live without
discomfort but the thing is so this was
like 15 maybe 18 years ago he had like
stunning growth he like he had to
collect I don't know if he had a
colostomy bag or like just like a large
section of the intestine taken out like
all the good all that stuff and I was
when I heard so when I heard this
reaction there's diagnosis I was like oh
my God this kid's like life but my
sister like myself like you don't
understand like in those 15 years
there's been so much progress made with
diagnosing and treating this condition
that it used to be straight to like a
colostomy bag you're gonna be a
malnourished she's like it's not that
way anymore like especially if you're
like kind of like a Whole Foods kid and
you're just eating like a whole food
yeah diet like she's like you're really
not going to be doomed and when I heard
that I was so relieved
oh good and she's already she already
knows that okay yeah but it's always
good to have like more information
yeah yeah no I I see people I mean I see
people with crazy diseases go on the
diet I'm doing and put themselves in
remission but a lot of people with
crohn's
um especially if you get it early if you
get it later then you're you obviously
there's more gut damage and things are
harder to get under control but um and
the thing that's interesting is like
like uh my brother-in-law is like well
at least it's not age or something like
that but the the joke is and I'm gonna
use the word a joke very broadly thanks
to all the research on AIDS there is so
much more understanding of how to fight
autoimmune diseases so it kind of does
spill over into other areas so it really
is yeah because I mean if you have it
now they could if you got AIDS you I I
I'll tell this story it's it's in poor
taste but I don't care I was with my
friend let's not mention her name let's
call her whatever jail and we're walking
down the street
in Manhattan and we ran to one of her
friends right and she's and she invited
him to lunch which I hate when people do
and she's like I had to do it I haven't
seen him in a long time so we're having
lunch it's fine and and we're at this
Diner and she uh Friedman's in Manhattan
he goes to the bathroom and she goes oh
um you know this one time when I thought
he was in the hospital with the flu it
was actually full-blown AIDS she's like
okay he's coming back from the bathroom
like wait what so he comes back but it
turns out first of all I learned a
couple things a if you wash your hands
enough times they will bleed but two if
you you can go from full-blown aids to
undetectable now meaning he couldn't
transmit it even if he wanted that's how
much under control uh AIDS has become
thank God so it really is so much better
than you know even before you were born
like you know and people it's just like
automatic a death sentence now it's not
that's cool I didn't know that that's
huge to get a virus under control too
yeah and to have it where it's
undetectable like you can't even pick it
up on a test and to go from full blown
to that
wow
wow okay well the medical system
does some things properly even though a
lot of the time I just spend insulting
it sometimes surgery surgery is very
useful as well but wow that's impressive
that's great
yeah so I'm very hopeful for his future
and besides we got a second one so
that's a spare hey guys I finally
launched after party this is The
Hangover pill I have been talking about
I mean it's not a hangover pill it's an
anti-hangover pill it's the pill I've
been talking about on my podcast for a
while it reduces my hangovers by 75 to
80 percent uh I came across a study on
rats when I was 20 I was dying in bed of
a hangover and I came across the study
on rats given dihydro myracetin and it
eliminates their hangover and it
eliminates a lot of the damage alcohol
does and I can remember talking to my
friends after I sourced it online in
these like sketchy powder formats being
like you guys have to try this it works
and they're just like Michaela what are
you talking about and they're still
suffering from hangovers so that's what
happens but you can go to
smartdrugs.life you can read a bunch of
scientific studies there you can order
it you can use code MP for 15 off
there's a 30-day money-back guarantee I
hope you guys enjoy it I never drink
without it and I wouldn't be selling a
supplement because I don't supplement
anything other than this
for my bourbon sodas if it didn't work
it works like the diet works so check it
out smartdrugs.life code MP for 15 off
30 day money back guarantee read the rat
study the route study is really funny
that's it that's all I have to say about
this try it do you have horns on your
chair yeah so I'm a Texan now
oh no nice super villain chair
that's
but but you know I gotta kind of um
I've got does it Cruella
what does it it doesn't spin too does it
oh yeah it does oh my gosh
so I got a Cruella to build thing going
so I've got like Mammoth tooth pens here
and my belt is from it's a hippo I don't
have a belt on me but yeah I'm I'm
basically my entire house is like a
kazoo that's hilarious you have a hippo
belt yeah a hippo leather and a giraffe
leather wallet oh here's a giraffe
leather wallet
wow there you go Texas I think the first
time I went to Texas I was in Fort Worth
and I went into one of those shops and
there were just emaciated stuffed lions
and a giraffe in there and was like this
is what Texas is I think this was 2018.
like this is horrifying but I was also
in I think I was an antidepressant
withdrawal at the time so everything was
kind of horrifying but these stuffed
animals was like this is terrifying
there were chandeliers that are just
made out of antlers and things it's
messed up I'm just imagining hey Scarlet
we got you a stuffed animal
you can we'll put it by your bed while
you sleep
just amazing lion yeah
like the eyes are sparkling in the dark
yeah
[Music]
that's good that's kind of how I felt in
Fort Worth that was also the first time
I saw a child riding a sheep at a rodeo
that's a thing yeah yeah
huh I never heard of that it's worth
seeing Fort Worth rodeos they have a
whole bunch of they're five-year-olds
and they put them on sheep to ride sheep
around I don't I feel like a sheep's
back isn't particularly strong
I don't know it works
okay
it works it's worth seeing
so what are you doing we okay the
purpose of this podcast yeah let's talk
about positive things she's just talking
talk crap for an hour and a half no to
talk about positive things what you're
looking forward to in the future what
you're happy about in the past year do
you want to start with
good things that have happened in the
last year
um sure I mean uh we're gonna talk again
when you finish reading my book but my
book the white pill I was working on it
for two and a half years so getting that
baby out of me was
um
uh but I was just something I'm very
happy about very pleased about it's
selling well so I can kind of cathartic
I think it was more like an exorcism
because you know while I'm writing about
all these horribly suffering people who
have like their stories just been swept
on the rug and kind of knowing you know
what happened the Soviet Union like what
why is communism so bad was it mean in
practice and when you just hear story
after Story you know there's that whole
line about like one murder is it one
death is a murder like one death is a
murderer and a million deaths is a
statistic right so each one of those
people there's literally millions of
people for decades you know had a story
of you know oppression my my buddy Trey
was just in the museum of Communism in
Prague which I highly recommend to
everyone if they're hurting Prague and
that was the first time that it kind of
hit me the extent to what my family had
to go through you know I was born in the
Soviet Union we escaped when I was you
know before I can remember I was like
one and a half or two but that whole
idea of like it's literally every aspect
of your life there's nowhere else to go
right if there's a political system we
don't like here in America let's say you
hate Trump or you hate progressives like
you can still to some extent get away
from it you could talk to people who are
different or you could read websites or
read books you you can't do that it's 24
7. and it not only affects your ideology
it's also the material stuff you know
there's no food you know you're cold
like it's just constant and like to have
that as the your background music since
the time you're born is something I
think it's almost impossible for us in
the west except for maybe some Cubans
you know what I mean in America to kind
of wrap their heads around so kind of
telling that story was very
I think cathartic I feel like it needs
to be discussed so much more
um and I mean it's discussed in the
context of like you have like
conservatives yelling that Biden's a
Marxist and all this other kind of scary
stuff but it's not really discussed what
this was like you know the second world
for for that long so I think kind of
telling these people's story was
something that I feel like I can go meet
my maker and be like okay you kind of
did your part
well good for you that's I'm I'm
interested I'm looking forward to
reading that book I've had so I left and
I don't want to compare Canada to the
Soviet Union because the Soviet Union
was on a completely different level yeah
but I know that how I feel being in
Canada is a stress just a societal
stress that I don't experience in
Florida
um and everybody there so I am comparing
them but I also recognize that it's not
the same but I think there's a little
bit of it there where everybody thinks
the same thing so you know um they're
like people are still wearing masks
there and everyone's stressed out and
everybody thinks like that so it's and
you can't really find people who don't
you know even if they kind of don't
they're still like oh no no this is how
you should think right and it's
stressful being there yeah my parents
were super stressed going even from
Australia back to Canada they're like oh
we're in Canada and it's just like
there's an underlying
fear or something there
it's creepy but it's also the kind of
thing where like in the states even as
divided as we are and hopefully are
going to increasingly become you are
painfully well yeah I wanted a national
divorce you are painfully aware that
there are people who think the other
side of you right this you can't really
get away from like alternative points of
view whether you know you hate whether
you're Progressive or whether you're a
republican you're going to be sensing
that other perspective but that and even
in New York you know which is very
liberal City you're still going to have
plenty of people who are likely to screw
all this but I think despite Canada's
Great diversity in thought there is a
great deal of homogeneity so this kind
of idea that like it's not even that
they would disagree with you it's I feel
like it's more like what are you even
talking about it's just like yeah like a
crazy person it's like wait even if I'm
wrong everyone I know who agrees with me
I know agrees with me so you're not
making any sense so it's even if they
want to be kind of open-minded from
their perspective you're like a flat
earther
yeah yeah yeah that's what's crazy about
that place in America you're aware that
there are people even if you hate them
you're aware that there are people on
the other side and Canadians I think
have always been brought up in a were
the reasonable country we've always been
the reasonable country we haven't been
like America Americans are kind of crazy
they're out there on both sides Canada's
always been in the middle and reasonable
and now that reasonable has just you
know they still think they're reasonable
but it's so far
I don't know if it's left or if it's
just an impingement on freedom but
there's definitely a stress there that
you don't experience in in Florida like
people are still scared it's very
unfortunate because Toronto is is such a
cool place
it's creepy I love Toronto
it's also they could say with a straight
face I can still man their argument
Trudeau's the moderate the NDP of the
left the conservatories are the
conservative are the right the Liberals
Trudeau's party are in the center so
like if you think Trudeau's too far to
the left something's wrong with you like
you can see how they get to that
conclusion
yeah it's wild anyway I'm glad I'm not
there anymore and I'm glad I was able to
you know and and it's still illegal
for Canadians to come here if they are
not vaccinated
oh I know okay that's crazy because you
can go there right but
but who aren't American can't come to
America unless they're not vaccinated
yeah now I've heard that they aren't
checking like they used to the people
have kind of stopped checking but that
doesn't mean it's like the airport
who's going to roll those dice at the
airport that's crazy no yeah yeah nobody
I know it's nuts
yeah that's just they're like yeah yeah
we're letting everything covet go but
also if you haven't been vaccinated you
can't come to our country still and and
what that means in practice is the
tourism industry which means Working
Families
yeah yeah
I feel like people aren't jumping up and
down about that like they were about a
lot of the Mask mandates
I I don't think it's on the radar screen
as much because it's so weird
um and second they just renewed it I
think it's going to be around until
April I think they said it's just it's
so weird
and it's not like Canada's some like
awful third world country where you have
some weird kind of like parasite right
you come in here and you're going to
spread it and everyone's going to get
that amoeba that goes in your eyes
that's right that's Canada
it's but the biggest undefended border
on Earth but still
yeah you can't get medicine there I went
there and I tried to get cough syrup for
scarlet and I couldn't get cough syrup
like Shoppers Drug Mart they're out of
kids medicine
wait you know in Canada in Canada yeah
so this isn't everywhere people in the
comments can be like well but no in
general there's a massive Children's
Medicine shortage in Canada and right
now emergency rooms are overrun because
RSV because kids have not been outside
and like
what three years basically and in Canada
like specifically a very long time
they're getting RSV and RSV is already
dangerous for kids
um they're getting it worse so emergency
rooms are having issues they've had
issues forever because they've always
been terrible but they're the RSV is way
worse and it's very difficult to get any
type of like cough medicine Tylenol for
kids it's like it look gives you
communism
how are the kids supposed to trip
I don't know
the scissor they're all out of scissor
we got the we got the lean but now we
need the medicine
these poor children I don't even know
where scissor was being stored in my
brain
a good old days the whitest girl on
earth
oh yeah there was a rough period of time
pretty much the entire time being a
teenager
I definitely knew what scissorb was uh
that's funny
that's good so okay moving away from
sizzurp and lean though
you mentioned that you'd be totally okay
if we had a national divorce
yeah I was the first one to get people
started talking about this when I had a
piece in early 2016 I brought it back
into like the natural Consciousness
um I think that it's I think it's
definitely heading in that direction uh
I think it's very healthy I think
America has had at least two ruling
ideology since the beginning and we've
been held together with like masking
tape and Staples and I don't see any
good reason and a few bad ones to
continue this charade that we're one
culture it's only a little confusing
because the language the shared language
and the shared history but language is
decreasingly shared in that you have
different popular like for example even
journalists if you're going to talk
about like one article on the right
we'll talk about tax increases the other
we'll talk about Revenue generation like
pronouns you know different terms are
used in different ways to these separate
cultures and of course each of those two
broader metacultures have subcultures
there's nothing
holding this country together everyone
hates each other so why continue with
this it's just like yeah it's gonna be a
painful conversation and how do you
divide it who gets the nukes but these
are all the questions that go on in
negotiation and I think the faster we
get started with this the better
I don't think there's any way that would
ever happen not opposed to it I just
don't see how it would ever happen well
what is California and New York are they
going to be together
that I can prove you wrong if I asked
you and everyone listening to this
in 2014 which was eight years ago which
of these two things is more likely
Texas declares its independence
from America or Donald Trump gets
elected president literally 99 of people
listening to this would say the first
one yeah yeah and they'd be correct
so it's I mean it doesn't have to be 50
50. it could be just Texas and I was on
the blaze for election night and we all
had to do our national divorce map and I
had Texas as one thing and then for the
rest I wrote IDGAF like I don't give an
f for the rest of the country like you
guys could do what you want like as long
as Texas reclaims that sovereignty will
be fine
you were already living in Texas at that
point or no
oh yeah I've been here for a year yeah
yeah uh I think Florida is better than
Texas
so I'm more of a fan of Florida how was
Florida this is the kind of rivalry you
could get my hand behind I was actually
very disappointed and as a former
lifelong New Yorker shocked that we're
at a point now where La is better than
New York City uh I was just in New York
over the summer because Tim Poole had
put up a billboard with me in Times
Square so I'm like all right bucket list
I gotta go see this thing in person and
then I was in LA as well and I'm like
holy crap I'd rather be in L.A it's less
screwed up less unsafe
more happening uh more thriving more
upbeat more like it was just very very
sad to see but I am very happy here in
uh Texas and there's lots of friends I
have in Florida who are also former New
Yorkers including my family my four
mentioned sister and nephews so they're
having a great time there so I don't
miss New York oh no I miss
New York with every fiber of my being
but uh she's dead so I don't need to see
this kind of corpse that they're beating
the crap out of on a daily basis
it hurts
that's interesting so I don't I'm not
that familiar with New York I've been to
New York twice this year I thought
compared to Toronto
it was doing okay but I it wasn't really
in it so I don't really know what the
difference was I went to California
though I thought California was in
pretty rough shape
it's it might be doing better than
Toronto but it's not doing better than
it was so I left in August of 2021 and
I'm like all right it's been a year
you know things have settled down with
with this absurdities of these lockdowns
and mandates whatever and I came back
and it was like a good 25 of the
storefronts were still unopened
um it's the crime is and like when
you're in New Yorker you just kind of
pick up on on say Vibes they were
through the roof compared to what it
used to be oh yeah I said this before
like I was I I was within an hour of
being there I saw a guy peeing on a
truck in the street not on the sidewalk
and people like oh that's just New York
for you I'm like no it's not like I've
been there all my life that's not a
thing like maybe you'll see someone
peeing against the building but like
against the truck in the street that you
know and during the daylight you know
what I mean it was right next to
McDonald's mind you so and all the
places I wanted to hit were gone like if
I'm you know I've set this point I don't
even know how many times by now if I
want to open up a restaurant or a
boutique or a cool stationery store all
the already it was like if you could
make it there you can make it anywhere
right so already the deck was stacked
against you at coming to New York to do
that but now it's it's just a complete
absolute almost impossibility and
especially because there's so many other
cities that are up and coming and
thriving like go there and be that big
fish in the small pond uh and you're
just gonna have the time of your life
doing it so I think that's the thing
that Austin and Miami to some extent
Nashville as well is my understanding
like these are the same cities where
people are refugees from their own
countries and they're this kind of
communities that are coming up are just
really exciting
here here I agree
I agree I'm glad you're having a good
time in Austin that's fun especially
having to uproot yourself
but you have a bunch of friends there
right you just party all the time how
often do you see other people
I see them all the time like that was
the thing I didn't realize towards the
end of New York is how lonely it got and
it wasn't just lonely because of
lockdown stuff it was lonely because
it's like you're playing poker right and
at certain points people like to write
about about like that's the straw that's
the straw and like one by one my friends
got picked off and then you just and
then also like once you leave it you
don't appreciate how brutal the winters
are you don't want to leave the house it
gets dark early you're in this kind of
Bunker mode and just when you think you
can't take another week of it that's
when it gets warm that's like the
seduction of New York and you're and
then you get to walk around and it's
warm and it's fun and great and then
like every year latherines repeat and
now I'm here with 80 degrees this week
you know in December and I'm like I
don't miss that cold weather like I miss
having opportunity to wear all these
cool sweaters I own but like that's a
price I'm willing to pay so uh it's it's
there's such
um a Venn diagram here of cool people
you know making things happen there's so
many different scenes is the biohacking
scene there's the the crypto scene
there's the podcasting scene there's the
comedy scene uh and there's just like
just Pete and there's that whole kind of
white people whole food scene
um which I'm not particularly party to
but there's just so much great stuff
happening here and everyone knows each
other so that kind of sends the
community is something New York
definitely used to have and completely
lost and now to have it rediscovered
here it's just really exciting I have
turned my space into my house into like
kind of a uh like a
like an event place and when people come
by throw parties for them it everyone
gets together and you know kind of bros
out it's really fun
that's fine I don't have that in Florida
yet I think because I haven't met that
many people and I'm kind of a I don't go
out a ton I have the people I work with
we're very good friends all the people I
pay to be friends with me are friends
with me but well I'm gonna be there next
I'm gonna be there next month we're
doing like a trip and I'm like all right
who wants to come Miami it's like 11 of
us
so we're gonna get like a like a mansion
Airbnb and it's gonna basically be like
Rock of Love or something it's gonna be
so much fun
okay amazing that sounds that sounds
great Miami's great I love it what
what's the worst thing about Austin
um the worst thing about Austin is it
kind of closes down early there's not
that much to do like New York there was
always something to do and here like it
there's not really that it's much more
something to do is like going to
people's houses and socializing as
opposed to like going to a museum going
to you know some cool restaurant that's
not as much of a thing here so that's a
little frustrating but like you know
I've got a buddy and we just go to
different places all the time and hang
out and we're discovering more and more
so uh that that kind of is a problem
it's a problem that's getting better
every day so that's kind of exciting
about it
okay that's cool
um I feel like Miami's got the opposite
problem I keep making dinner plans I
made dinner plans at six and was just
laughed at they're like no no dinner is
at nine then you go to the bar at 12 and
then at four a.m there's a performance I
was like what 4 AM
I can't handle that well I go to bed at
two what time do you go to bed
okay well since I met Jordan
um he's just destroyed apparently he had
a good sleep schedule before he met me
too and we've just destroyed each
other's sleep schedule from like working
too late and like talking too much it's
basically enjoying each other it's good
it's enjoying each other's company
enough that it's disrupting my sleep
schedule and making me into a worse
person so it's not ideal but I used to
go to sleep at 10 30 like I need to go
to sleep at 10 30.
um and now I probably go to sleep at
like
12 or midnight uh 12 or 1. and it needs
it needs and this is what happens when
you go to sleep late I was um no it's
it's
I was thinking but I'm destroying my
brain I had a friend from Prague I have
a friend from Prague Simon and he has a
funny accent so we always make fun of
him like he's like for some like Martian
country and like I just told him that
what do you guys have like a 36 hour day
over there and like you know you don't
whatever and we went to a cafe and the
cafe said it was open until 14 at 14 a.m
and I'm like look I told you you guys
have a 36 hour day here he's like what
the hell is that so yeah but it's fun
it's I like being a night owl
um because there's something a little
like kind of cool about being outside
when everyone's asleep
you just feel like likes like you're
kind of a rule breaker in like the
easiest way possible
uh I don't know I can't do it anymore
and I feel like my mom always went to
bed at like 9 30 or 10 and she just
disappeared
she just disappeared and my dad would be
like did your mom go to sleep without
saying anything again and that was like
just every single night
and and now he goes to bed early too but
I I can feel her in me making me tired
enough that I get like get like rageful
if I stay up like it hurts my body
staying up I used to go to bed at two no
problem and like I can't do it
wake up early I'm really a nasty nasty
piece of work
um if I don't get my sleep if I wake up
early I can't do it
okay okay so I think the problem with me
is I have to wake up early so I'm waking
up early and going to sleep so going to
sleep late is kind of the equivalent of
waking up too early I know that the
later I stay up the less sleep I'm
getting and it makes me rage full
optimistic and happy about I mean
getting married is a big one
yeah
getting married was great that was
fantastic
[Music]
um
I was always worried probably in a
relationship that I'd get bored yeah uh
because I get bored of I get bored I
need a lot of different activities to do
um I wouldn't be able to just have like
one job get bored of the job so I was
always worried I'd get bored and it
hasn't been I mean it hasn't been super
long
still a short relationship but I'd
usually get bored around the nine month
Mark I'm pretty standardly and I'm most
definitely not bored so that's a huge
relief
uh because I I had like I had decided as
a person especially going through a
divorce and having a kid I had decided
okay I'm going to be by myself forever
and I had just become okay with that
because I was pretty good at being alone
too yeah it was like having a kid and
being alone is quite lonely it like adds
a level of loneliness having a kid at
the same time even though it's another
person
um but I've gotten used to the idea of
being alone so not being alone is so
much better like I'm such an extroverted
person that I would rather spend I was
actually I was talking to Chris
Williamson about this
because I was like I I actually enjoy
spending 95 of my time or even like 98
of my time with another person if I like
that other person okay like whether
that's your friends or or a relationship
I like I hate being alone even if I'm
working I used to go work in cafes so I
was so at least there were people around
me
and he said he's like the opposite he'd
rather spend 95 of his time alone
it's like ugh I I got it off to be like
that until very recently and I don't
know what changed in me but I always
consider myself to be a hardcore
introvert I still do but now I'm
realizing that if I don't like see
someone every day or like fairly
regularly I start to go crazy
and that I'm not as interested I thought
I was now that that being said I don't
think most people are
are fun to spend extended amounts of
time with
um like like you said like a lot of
people like they're just it's just like
small talk or like you know their
opinions on whatever's in the news and
it's like you get you're not gonna have
that kind of intense fun I took
something away from I don't have a
conversation with someone what I haven't
experience with someone right like a
story like let's do something awesome
let's tell me something amazing like
that those kind of relationships are the
kinds of things that make life just so
much more exciting and interesting
um and not that many people can deliver
that uh but yeah I I the other thing
that's a problem that I had to learn is
when you your brain tries to get you to
isolate when it's not doing well so if
you are like feeling lonely it'll tell
you not to reach out to people and then
it becomes the spiral and you have to
override it and be like okay my brain's
giving me the absolute worst advice go
out and hang out with someone you like
uh even just go get ice cream it doesn't
matter just do something and it'll
you'll human beings are much more social
animals than we let ourselves realize
even those of us who are like fiercely
independent
yeah I agree that's that's what's rough
about depression too I think is that you
get depressed and then your brain tells
you to be by yourself and then that
contributes to being depressed and yeah
like you said that's rough but good
things good things so getting it
actually has good
I I actually had to deal with that in
the last week because the book came out
which I've been working again for so
long and then like there was a little
issue with Amazon with the pricing which
was resolved in a day and they haven't
even sent them out yet right and like it
was kind of a big
um anti-climax it's not like a movie
premiere where you have the premiere and
there's a red carpet and everyone's
there right it's like the book's out and
then it's kind of like crickets even
though the sales are very good it was
like the top new release in politics for
the week take that corporate Publishers
and then I was talking to my buddy and
she's like you're you're so used to
Media where you put out a tweet or a
YouTube and you get instant feedback
that when you didn't get that you're
thinking this is like a flop even though
you haven't even started your promotion
tour so no wonder you're like feeling
like all like all kinds of way when I
realized that I'm like holy crap this is
as old media as it gets like books give
it time to breathe it hasn't even
reached people's hands yet then I was
like oh okay yeah yeah I can relax I
just I am someone who's very bad and I'm
sure a lot of your listeners are the
same way someone who's very bad at
relaxing and telling myself it's okay to
have a day where you're just messing
around and watching shitty TV and and
just not doing anything it's it's fine
you know what I mean like but it's hard
for me to do that sometimes especially
after two years of working on something
that's so intense to kind of and it's
like it's it's okay like to take a week
off after two years of producing a book
that you're very proud of
oh yeah 100 I'm terrible at that as well
and it's it's silly because you can burn
yourself out you can't just work all the
time you actually need to take the rest
time to recover so you can be more
productive but I have such like guilt
and an antsy feeling if I'm not working
on something or pushing a project
forward or making progress in some way
uh
yeah I know I'm terrible at that so I
feel you I feel ya but also for for you
I mean have you you haven't started
podcasting and talking about the book
yet right
yeah like this is like this is the first
one this isn't even really the real one
you haven't read it yet so I've got all
these shows booked in January
um I haven't even gotten my physical
copies it's got these like author copies
not resale so I can't even you know what
I mean that's cool maybe when I get my
own copy then I can start yeah yeah so
it was fun
um yeah so it's it's a
it's it's just um it's exciting to have
it done
um and I I really am thinking 2023 is
going to be a very good the thing is a
lot of people I know
and I want to hear your thoughts with
like the people you know are really
going through it right now and I reached
out to another friend of mine and
because she's you know has to deal with
has had to deal with postpartum after
her kid and I asked her for feedback she
goes you understand like everyone I know
right now is just kind of suffering in
some way and it's not you and books are
hard and I'm like oh okay that made me
relief but I feel like a lot of people I
know are really just kind of not in a
good way is that been your experience
with your like social group
you know um honestly I don't
um
not really a couple of months ago it was
a couple of months ago I had like it was
ridiculous I had like six major serious
work issues come up like serious work
issues come up in the same week like it
all happened at the same time and I was
asking people and everyone was talking
about how they were having a rough time
so I feel like the impacts also of of
covid and how weird it's made the world
hasn't worn off on people I think my
experience is a little bit different
because I dealt with my dad being so
sick
for like two solid years so there was
just nothing and that was so awful that
anything now
is not like that that was just like
movie Drama Bad
um so things are pretty good I'm
physically exhausted
and I think I might be coming down with
a horrifying toddler flu but um other
than that
things are pretty good yeah so this
might be my last podcast we'll see if I
make it through that whatever Scarlett
has
children are a blessing
laughs
it's funny like I didn't what else so
what else are you hopeful about for uh
the next year like is there something
big project that's like on the shelf or
something oh yes yes uh I've been
working on Peterson Academy I saw the
logos yeah I like them oh yeah yeah
we're trying to we put it up on Twitter
and for like the first time in my
experience of Twitter people were
helpful they're like well kind of
they're like that sucks you shouldn't
use either of them it's awful but here
are some Alternatives and there were
some good ideas in there so we're making
different iterations of uh of the logo
now but I've been working pretty hard on
Peterson Academy we're going to launch
late next year okay and so that's I'm so
excited about that I think it's gonna be
huge hopefully we completely decimate
the current University system which is
just such a scam
um I think if it was just a scam I would
feel a lot less contempt and animosity
towards these people if it was just like
you gotta you know like how um if it's
just like you got to pay 100 Grand to
get this piece of paper to have this job
and it's just a con like I can wrap my
head around it but the fact that they're
turning so many people into like Camille
palia who's like probably my biggest
role model she just made the comment
that campus college campuses are
institutionalized Neurosis that there
they make people mentally ill by Design
um the fact that they're harming so many
people even the debt aside that to me is
the real problem and what I'm most
excited about is you know the three legs
of the cathedral stool are uh the
government uh the media and the
universities and the universities in my
opinion are not only the most malevolent
but also have been the most Beyond most
Untouchable because government people
attack politicians constantly that's
their job they know it's their job
they're gonna get you run for an office
the other person is going to call you a
demon that's that's part of the gig uh
media you've had media criticism it's
amped up and journalists especially now
in in Canada are like crying that like
wherever they go they just get inundated
with uh nowhere near as much hatred and
animosities they deserve but College
professors no one ever to talk like
other than like people who are public
figures like your dad or um you know
Stephen Pinker for example they were
kind of like totally behind the
barricades and now thanks to social
media they are really feeling the fire
and anything that gets them to lose
their status and respectability and
cloud is just the most wonderful and
that is what's going to save America is
defeating this the enemy class so the
fact that it it is already in 2020 and I
think literally all the signs are in the
positive direction yeah if I had to
choose between a Harvard degree and
start starting a business at age 18 and
like being self-taught through either
Peterson Academy or YouTube videos I
would still choose the Harvard degree
because that credential is as good as it
gets but that lead is shrinking daily
and and it's not going to last for much
longer and already it's the case that
there are some startups where they see
an Ivy League credential and they think
two things this person is probably very
bright and this person's probably going
to be trouble because they're going to
be bringing their infected ideology and
causing a problem for me in my office
and like I don't have enough [ __ ] on
my desk running this startup that I need
to deal with their [ __ ] two cents
about every and politicizing literally
everything so I think that is something
that is going to be changing in an
entirely positive direction in the next
five to ten years and I don't see how
they recover from it in the same way as
publishing like it wasn't that long ago
five ten years that like Simon choose to
publish me or penguin or rent a house
it's still a major deal but now like
people like me David Goggins there's
like no shortage of people who are
putting their work out themselves it's
not in the bookstores but it's still on
Amazon Goggins I think is it's still on
Amazon the same as any other book and
it's like what that Random House
um credential gave me is almost now
entirely worthless if not a detriment
I've been trying to kind of talk to Dad
about that he's like yeah but it's
penguin because he wanted to be
published by penguin first of all so
long like throughout his life and was
like nobody cares anymore yeah no one
cares anymore it doesn't matter because
I'm sorry like if you ask people on the
street which is a bigger credential
Jordan Peterson or penguin it's really
not a lot of people hate him but I I
don't think even me who works in who's
got how many dozen books under his belt
if someone says I'm with penguin I'm not
like
or as opposed to like oh I have an
interview with Jordan Peterson like
which of those two things is going to be
more impressive right it's it's night
and day yeah crazy
crazy we're we're trying to so with
Peterson Academy we're trying to get
around the the accreditation part we're
trying to get accredited first of all
and it would be absolutely crazy if we
could get kind of up to date eight hour
courses taught in a you know either
freestyle lecture or kind of q a if we
can get that kind of thing accredited
that would be insane but I I've also
been thinking like if you can get a
degree and you can show employers that
this degree is valuable if you can go to
employers and say hey this is a Peterson
Academy student would you hire them and
they say yes then then the degree part
kind of becomes worthless yes if it's
supposed to lead to a job all you need
to do is become a student that's good
enough to get hired and so yeah I think
it's silly like the Harvard degree yes
it's worth a lot just to get that degree
but
um it's not it's not useful right
compare and and it's ridiculous that you
can go on YouTube and you can go online
and you can learn way more in a shorter
period of time than you can at
University but that's not taken
seriously
so there's this Gap right now and
hopefully Peterson Academy can kind of
fill that Niche because there's a huge
niche of an area that's an issue so I'm
very excited for that yeah very I don't
think they see it coming I think in
their minds and they're not entirely
wrong
Harvard will always be Harvard like the
Catholic church for us to always be the
Catholic Church it'd always be the pope
but what the pope is now is not what the
pope was you know 200 years ago and same
with Harvard what it is now it does not
have to be what it was 20 years ago 50
years ago and it's still going to be a
great [ __ ] to have and it's just a great
okay you went to Harvard but to have
that be the be-all and end-all I mean
it's because there's so many young
people and I'm sure in your audience as
well who are like the tools are there
Shopify with a Big Cartel whatever it is
who are out there making something
happen and if you have a job interview
and you're like I don't have a degree
but like I started this t-shirt company
and this is how much sales we make and I
understand the inside and out like I
want to hire that kid as opposed to
someone who has a degree who hasn't
accomplished anything I mean that's the
the biggest
you know to be a pragmatist in a
philosophical sense the biggest proof of
the efficacy of some philosophy is that
it actually works and this kid has shown
that it works
yeah yeah for sure I know and I'm
probably more biased uh well I'm way
more biased than maybe the average
employer but I've hired a couple of
people and I'm not saying everyone from
Colombia has this issue but I hired a
couple of people who had master's
degrees from Columbia being like oh this
person is going to be right
so awful such awful human beings that
now I'm
unfortunately anyone who has a Columbia
degree I'm like oh my gosh just in case
they're like that those other people I
hired from Colombia that's going to be
an issue then I've hired people who've
been doing social media and are making
money on their own and have an online
product and understand like you said
Shopify or something they're like hey
I'm 21 but I've built this whole thing
and I'm like okay you're like you take
take you while you're young you're going
to be a very useful person as opposed to
someone who's like 30 and has a master's
degree and thinks that they're smarter
than you they also have the thing with
those 30 year old those Columbia people
is they have this sense of entitlement
but also what's worse is that there's no
sense of shame in this in the idea of if
they screw up something really bad
because I was a business major but
there's something they beat into us like
you if you are given ownership of like a
project or part of a project or project
as you would say like you have to make
sure that you it's it buck stops here
but with them it's like oh I didn't get
around to doing it or oops and it's like
you screwed up this whole thing and it's
just like people make mistakes it's like
but you're in charge this was your
responsibility and there's they
completely don't understand or care that
like it's it's like it's it's like their
work isn't their problem and to me
that's so yeah maybe it's because I'm
self-made to have that kind of be your
background music I I can't talk to
people like that I don't get it yeah
I I no I don't get it I don't get it at
all you're supposed to clearly they
haven't been listening to Jocko at all
right but like extreme ownership you
should be feeling I think it's better to
feel guilt for things that you didn't
have control over not guilt necessarily
but responsibility for things you didn't
have control over I think that's the
only way I got out of my autoimmunity at
some point I was like okay
um it's not exactly my fault but
something I'm doing is wrong yeah right
and that's the only way otherwise it's
like nothing I'm doing is wrong I've
been listening to everyone else and then
you're just stuck being sick forever or
or like while obese people for instance
too you're like you're doing something
to put your body in that situation even
if you there's a whole bunch of a set of
unfortunate circumstances like getting
diagnosed at five years old with crohn's
that's not your fault
but unfortunately you have to take some
responsibility you can't when you're
five obviously unfortunately you have to
get older so it's fortunate that his mom
is like aware of these things but even
if your situation absolutely sucks I
think the only way kind of out of it is
to take responsibility for it
she's very big and like I'm not gonna
ruin his quality of life I'm not gonna
have him thinking myself as I'm a victim
so they're having like a little birthday
party for the class and she's she's like
oh maybe he shouldn't come the teacher
got on the phone she's like no no the
kids are like him get him there and it's
like okay you can't have the regular
cookies You're Gonna Bake those special
cookies that you can eat and you're
gonna give them out to the whole class
yeah so instead of you being nice it's
like okay now we're all taking part in
this activity everyone's gonna enjoy it
the cookies are delicious and it's
you're owning it and without having to
feel like you're missing on anything
oh that's great that's the right way to
go about it with Scarlet I do she has
birthday cake but it's like a watermelon
with fruit around it okay I was like
okay yeah Jenny it's been in green so
long too I think it's almost easier when
you're younger like imagine trying to
change your diet and stop eating normal
cool foods like pizza when you're like
13 or 14.
that's hard no I mean I mean that's for
the kids who become vegan and they're
all like miserable
yeah true that's true it's the girl who
listens liqueur maybe they don't do that
anymore with people your age but they
listen to cure and she writes in her
journal with fingers gloves and she goes
to Hot Topic and she you know it's I
remember her fingers yeah she won't eat
meat and she's not a happy camper and
I'm sure her her um cycle is all screwed
up too so it's a big birth control as
well yeah
brutal brutal okay
is there anything else you're excited
about in the future this is one of the
most depressing like white white pillows
so whatever welcome to the white film so
Crohn's uh people who are incompetent
the university system fleeing New York
fleeing can our countries ruined my
cities ruined my nephew's health is
ruined yeah yeah this is this has been a
bit of a downer I know like end the year
on a positive note everything will be
fine
do you know what the biggest positive
note is and I'm sure you will agree with
this and most people agree with watching
school as well
it has become so much easier and people
are seeking out so much more to connect
with one another now that this coveted
uh regime has receded people are doing
things together they're going to shows
they're traveling more
um they're interacting more they're not
in that bunker mentality they don't have
to worry about being yelled at on the
street in for the most part I'm sure
someplace like in Boston it's still an
issue that's fine I think that
Renaissance in the idea of community is
something in at least in my experience
and experience of pretty much everyone I
know is very much on the rebound and I
think that is something that I am
extremely excited about looking forward
uh in the coming year because we I think
a lot of us I'm sure a lot of us if not
all of us lost a lot of our
relationships or or they all took a hit
during the last couple of years uh
especially because there was this kind
of binary where either you wear a mask
or you're indifferent to human life
right that's the mentality and I think
that that's not that's kind of off the
table and people don't have to have that
very basic like you're you're both
people looking at each other like
they're crazy like now that that's kind
of receded I think people are
reestablishing those bonds
um and I think
if you're someone who's out there who is
all alone and I I certainly count a lot
of those people like among my fans in my
audience reach out to like social media
for all its you know negativity and
hostility is really a great mechanism to
find people to talk to of a like-minded
of a like-mind find a hobby it could be
stupid right but I'm sure that the
people who breed like guinea pigs they
have a thriving community and I'm sure
that there's this group who hates that
group and they think they're the worst
and these ones hate this ones because
they're not the real breeders point
being there's so many activities out
there that are easy for someone to find
and go down a rabbit hole and get
excited about and there's going to be
other people like that and it's a very
easy way if you haven't been effective
at making friends on an interpersonal
level in your life doesn't mean you're
gonna have to be alone forever uh they
don't even have to know your name so if
people are kind of repudiating you
online change your behavior change your
change something about it you have that
control to be a more social person next
year than you have been this year and
it's it may take trial and error a lot
of people are socially awkward but
that's the beauty of the internet you
have the anonymity so you can kind of
figure out what works for you and just
do some research and and read some
articles about like okay what makes how
do you make friends I think people don't
even realize that that's a technical
skill that they can develop
um and you know humans have these
courtship rituals and they work in not
just romantically they work in socially
and a lot of times people are friends
with people at their work because
they're kind of forced or school because
you're stuck together and when you're
like working at home you're going to
lose that you lose that human contact
how do you regain it well there's lots
of different mechanisms for doing that
and I think that's the kind of thing I
would encourage more people who are
lonely and there's a lot of them out
there to be like wait a minute this is
something that I can improve on
um and it's going to take me out of my
comfort zone but that's kind of fun too
to try new experiences
I love that that's great yeah no that's
a great idea in social media groups
even I don't like Facebook but even
Facebook groups they're dying off but
even Facebook groups are a good place
Facebook Facebook groups are a really
good place to meet people
but
um Twitter I know a lot of people have
met on Twitter I know like most of my
good friends are through social media
yeah almost all of them maybe all of
them and then they introduce you to
other people and it's it's then you're
kind of pre-vetted so you have this
element of familiarity right from the
from the jump so it's it's just really
um
uh uh just a great thing and I think I
wish more people the thing that I talk
about and I I know you agree with this a
lot is we are so if you like with me
with with having stomach issues right if
you live a certain way your life your
entire life just like you with your
autoimmune I'm sure in your head you
think this is how I'm gonna be when I'm
80. and then once that first thing that
you had had your whole life changes you
realize wait a minute every aspect of my
life is open to change it's not going to
be perfect but it can be improved and
that sense of freedom is almost
existential uh it's really very very
liberating and exciting
yeah I I like that that's what happened
to me like like you said was as soon as
one part fell away I was like oh my gosh
how much of it then three more parts
fell away and I was like oh no is it
Everything is Everything malleable is
everything a lie but it's good because
that means you have control and you have
control in a way it took me a long time
to understand I had control of my
relationship
which I I think people get you know how
people get trapped in relationships and
you're like why are you still in that
and then I don't know like I'm a
yeah and I'm like I'm a bright person
but it took me a long time to wrap my
head around that like I had control of
my relationship so also if you're stuck
somewhere in a relationship you don't
like
and you have been for like five years
you should not be in that relationship
anymore you should just end it your life
is going to get better not worse people
have that sunk cost fallacy where
they're like it's think about this way
if you have a house and it costs you a
hundred thousand dollars and then every
month you gotta get a new roof new
garage new get kitchen appliances new
floor whatever and you're like oh I
spent 200 Grand in this house now yeah
that's like you know what doesn't you
have to spend another million like that
money is gone you're not ever seeing
that money again right or those five
years are gone just because you've spent
five and I'm sure large parts of it of
those five were good does not mean you
have to spend the next 50. and like and
it doesn't mean you even if you and this
idea like is this really the being a
single for a while is also not the end
of the world it sucks dating sucks it's
horrible but is this I I had a I had a
good friend and he got divorced and it
was just this long ugly process and he
had been trying to make it work and then
you just had to Epiphany he just goes
wait a minute I'm not going to die
miserable alone F that you know and now
he's married and has a great wife and
it's just wonderful again but it's just
it sucks there's no question but the
status quo you're in sucks too and if
you're in a relationship that kind of
sucks after five years
the odds are almost 100 it's going to be
much worse than another few it's not
going to go the other direction
yeah the first five years were awful but
then it turned around yeah
I hated this even any any situation I
really hated this job and it got better
no it's just gonna suck more
what TV show gets good in the sixth
season
yeah
that's a good point that's a good point
okay Michael
it was lovely seeing you oh that's fast
okay I will see you I have to I have to
go I'll see you in a few weeks and I
look forward to yeah that sounds like
fun and I hope everyone watching this
from the bottom of my heart has a
thriving and happy 2023 and I promise
you you have enough power in you in you
to make it better than you think it is
inevitably going to be
beautiful well I'm so excited to see you
congratulations on your book I will read
it and we will talk again and I'll see
you soon
[Music]